Thank You Tina it is great to be here
you know ETL was actually a favorite of
mine when I came to Stanford almost 25
years ago and in fact even when I was at
the Business School almost 10 years
later I used to sneak over here because
you guys always have these great great
talks and speakers and when Tina asked
me actually to give this talk I have to
say it was with some amount of sort of
trepidation because I was thinking about
the fact that 25 times a year you all
get to hear from these sort of fully
formed successful Silicon Valley
executives and leaders dropping wisdom
on sort of you all from their sort of
decades of experience and I kind of was
thinking about well the seals feel
sometimes like these like these massive
live oak trees that are all over campus
and they're just like beautiful and
large and strong but we sometimes forget
that like they were little seedlings at
one time and there are all these
experiences that sort of add another
ring or a branch to each of that sort of
greater whole
so as Tina said I've had a lot of
different experiences and roles in in my
career here starting out as a product
designer then as an entrepreneur and and
now as an investor so I thought it would
be fun to actually deconstruct a few of
the lessons that I have kept learning
over and over again from these many
experiences or as I sometimes think
about them now is from Steve's jobs now
the first job I ever had was actually
when I was a kid so I grew up in
Worcester Massachusetts and if you know
Worcester a couple of you it's about
it's a working-class City about about an
hour west of Boston and Worcester is
known for three things it was actually a
booming industrial center in the last
century it was the home to the Robert
Goddard one of the founding fathers of
modern rocketry but the thing that I
remember most were the crazy nor'easter
snowstorms that would literally bury the
city one or two times a year with like 1
to 2 feet of snow so let me tell you
about the motivation behind my first job
I was actually the ninth child in a
family of 10 kids so the majority of the
things that I grew up with were actually
hand-me-downs from my eight older
siblings and there were actually ten
years and four sisters between me and my
next older brother so pretty much all
the stuff that was handed down to me was
either out of style or altogether out of
gender but when I was eight my dad came
home with this lime-green go-kart from
the Auburn Sears & Roebuck and he had
picked this up at a deep discount
because it had actually been sent to the
wrong store now I was immediately hooked
and I used to take that go-kart out rain
or shine
whenever I could and zoom around the
neighborhood sometimes sneaking over to
the school and in fact all I wanted to
do now is make this thing go faster and
when my dad would look the other way I
would lean out the carburetor so I could
kind of eke out an extra mile or two per
hour and this little four horsepower
go-cart really was the beginning of my
obsession for cars and all things that
go fast so when I turned 13 I saw review
and one of my favorite motorsports
magazines for this crazy cool dune buggy
that Honda had just launched it had a
350 cc two-stroke engine a fully working
suspension and very importantly a roll
cage so that I can rationalize to my
parents that it was actually safer than
the go-kart that I'd been racing around
him but in order to underwrite this
passion I was gonna need to get a job
other than the Sunday morning paper
route I had at the time
now I didn't actually want to bag
groceries at fortin's which is where my
older brothers had worked and I just
figured out how to run the snowblower
that I had been using to clear the
driveway and the sidewalks from those
crazy nor'easter snowstorms and that's
when the light bulb went off in my
internal-combustion addicted middle
school mind I would sell my services
snow blowing services to all of my
neighbors now I had a decent snowblower
wasn't a great one but it was good
enough to get started the next thing I
needed was an identity business cards of
course so I convinced the head of the
seventh-grade print shop to let me bail
on the basically the mock book cover
project and instead I built my first
business cards in print shop class
and this was now Steve snow-blowing
services so I actually still carry one
of these things in my wallet today it's
a great reminder and from this little
business I learned the first version of
three really important lessons number
one learn how to sell so I had a
snowblower and I had business cards and
now all I needed was customers total
dread I mean this idea of going to my
neighbors and selling them my services
was just completely paralyzing to me to
the point where I can still remember
walking up their steps
standing on their front porch and
staring at the door knocker with just
abject fear and then I would kind of
muster everything I had knock on the
door and deliver my pitch and the first
few times just totally sucked and then I
landed my first customer mrs. paintin
she had a long driveway and a lot of
steps which was the very manual part so
she was worth 40 bucks a storm and then
I locked down the Tinsley's and then the
Rice's two doors down from them and
pretty soon I was beginning to kind of
push past the confines of my street
which is literally still stained with
this very ironic dead-end sign on the
corner and now I was seeing okay more
sort of top step doorbell dread more
butterflies but more customers and
pretty soon I had to upgrade to a much
more powerful eight horsepower snow
blower and I also upgraded my print shop
business cards to these much fancier
Flyers that I painstakingly designed on
the IBM 8086 computer that we had in our
basement and this was the second lesson
that I learned design matters I must
have made 30 different versions of these
business cards with 50 different fonts
and spacings in alignment and I'm
convinced that my customer
took me more seriously and I could
probably charge them more because it was
clear that I actually cared and that
dovetails to the third lesson that I
learned take out the garbage my dad used
to say no matter what it is to you
choose to do in life just do it with
excellence if you want to be a garbage
collector just be the best darn garbage
collector there is be ready and willing
to take on the unglamorous tasks
changing the oil and greasing the
bearings of that snowblower in between
every snowstorm was a total drag but
guess what it never broke down during
one of those big storms and by the time
that I had turned 14 I was making $400
per storm because I had committed myself
to this little business in these ways I
came at this realization that were all
natural-born entrepreneurs oh I got that
dune buggy in fact I still have that
dune buggy no joke so eventually I went
off to school to WPI where I studied
engineering and robotics
I built this this was the lightest si
formula race car of its time from
scratch along with half a dozen
classmates a mine I studied abroad in
Germany and then Switzerland thinking
that I wanted to be an automotive
engineer and then figured out that this
industry was way too conservative and
slow-moving for my taste so I came here
a Stanford to get a master's in
engineering now this was a really good
decision because I met my wife in me2 18
Thank You ed Carriere and I also met
David Kelly during my first Friday here
on campus when he opened my eyes to the
world of product design a few months
later after seeing my final Emmy 101
project that was a grad student at the
time David came up to me and said as you
guys have heard him probably in his
plaintiff wine say
you got to work at I do this summer and
that summer was a total blast and the
beginning of five amazing years at IDEO
which is an incredibly special place I
started out as an individual contributor
building skills pulling all-nighters and
putting into practice a lot of the
things that you all learn here at
Stanford things like user observations
and need finding and rapid prototyping
and they actually totally overlooked but
hugely important role of storytelling I
worked on everything from toys to
furniture anesthesia delivery devices
Nikes first sunglasses rapid bun toaster
for McDonald's I actually went to
hamburger University no joke and through
the prism of these different experiences
and projects
I learned that yes design does matter
but design is a lot more than tuning the
pixels on that snow-blowing flyer design
was actually about the what it was about
asking the right questions and solving
problems of all manner and level of
importance it was actually not
necessarily about giving users or
clients that I do what they had asked
for but oftentimes giving them something
that when they saw it was what they
wanted all along so I did this a few
times over at IDEO and about four years
in I got asked to lead a very
high-stakes project to develop a family
of voice over IP phones for Cisco now
why was this such a big deal
so my initial proposal for this project
was three million dollars which was four
times larger than the largest project I
had ever leaded IDEO and the largest
project did I do at the time Cisco was
actually one of the Silicon Valley
darlings it was closing in on a market
cap of half a trillion dollars and it
was clear that if we were successful on
this project there would be a lot more
work to come and then for me this was a
bit of a magnum opus project I would be
working with the best people in each of
the disciplines that I do including Bill
I'm rich who was literally the founding
father of the field of interaction
design oh and Cisco they had never
designed a product with an actual user
interface never mind a phone that would
touch her face 50 times a day like
that's a product you got to get right so
high stakes on many fronts but I thought
I had this and then we have our kickoff
meeting and all these big wheels joined
from Cisco Mario Missoula Lucca Cafiero
these are the Cisco mafia as they were
affectionately known and they had these
super strong opinions about what we were
supposed to build and I immediately
realized that this is going to be like
one very spicy meatball to manage this
team and then they introduced me to my
counterpart whose name is also Steve and
you literally just joined the company
two weeks prior to the kickoff meeting
so he had actually not been involved in
the whole proposal process but he wasted
no time in telling me about his 20 year
career in telecom at this very prominent
company at the time and how he knows
better than me about what the market and
the users really want and about all
these things we have to get done and
then he hands me with an almost satanic
smile this hundred page product
requirements document the infamous PRD
and this thing is just loaded with
features and functions and telephony
jargon that I had never seen before and
as he's walking me through this thing he
makes this point that still sticks with
me which was that business phones so
enterprise phones at the time had this
sort of secret symbolic sort of meaning
around how much power you had in the
company so more features meant more
buttons meant more power so like the CEO
had one of those giant phones with lots
and lots of buttons so they could call
anybody directly so here's this guy
who's brand-new to this hope
high-profile project has just started a
super
strong conviction about what we're
supposed to build he has no interest in
user experience doesn't give a lick
about design and he's gonna be the guy
who I have to interact with literally a
couple times a week and and and build a
team around so I definitely had my work
cut out for me so here I was back to
square one
back to doing the hard work of user
observations and ethnography and need
finding and building prototypes back to
the hard work of being a user centered
designer so instead of just accepting
that PRD at face value I set up visits
to go meet with a bunch of users who
live on desk phones all the time we went
to a call center in the East Bay a
trading floor so these are people who
literally worked every day on their
phones and by doing this I learned which
features they understood and used all
the time and which ones made no sense in
fact I still remember seeing this phone
that had Sharpie markings all over it
because the user had no idea what the
flash button actually meant I'm not sure
I still know what it means either and
these were some other priceless
on-the-ground insights that we absorbed
that helped us build a much deeper more
informed more intuitive sense for what a
great desk phone could and should be and
that's when we began the hard work of
synthesizing putting all this stuff
together so we went back through that
insane list of features and functions
and we graphed each one of them in terms
of their frequency and their immediacy
so on this graph from left to right low
frequency or as low immediacy at high
immediacy and then bought top to bottom
low frequency to high frequency so those
features that were high frequency and
high immediacy so things like dialing a
number or hanging up on someone quickly
or changing the volume on your handset
you had to access those with a hard key
you had to get those right away but then
there were all these features that had
context associated with them so joining
two calls or transferring a call
those were kinds of features that you
could you could surface that
functionality only when you needed it
and then there were all these features
which were in the low frequency low
immediacy quadrant things like changing
your ringtone you might do it once you
need it but it is such a low frequency
thing that we could actually have it
buried deep down in the interface so
instead of our phone having hundreds of
buttons and looking like the cockpit of
a 747 we developed and launched the
world's first truly dynamic display
based phone interface so features and
apps that you use all the time would be
right there on the top of the unit user
interface hierarchy kind of like today
having those four apps at the bottom of
your homescreen
on your iPhone and functions that were
more contextual could be surfaced only
when you needed them now I realize you
all use smart phones today and this
seems like a really obvious in their
insight from like a million years ago
but at the time breaking that dogma of
more features means more buttons was
actually a pretty big deal that actually
ushered in the era of phones that would
enable inner that had interfaces that
would enable an infinite number of apps
and an infinite number of features and
functionality without having to have an
infinite number of buttons and that was
a pretty big deal in fact I mean my
iPhone has this wonderful IPO coated
chemically reinforced glass but it only
has three buttons on it right maybe four
if you if you count the slide switch now
not only were these phones transformed
but this entire industry was turned
upside down
companies like Nortel and Nokia which
used to have close to 50% market share
and didn't make this shift they
literally are gone
and Cisco and Apple which hadn't made a
phone are now basically owning these
categories so guess what happened to
other Steve my Cisco counterpart the guy
who is the keeper of the PRD and who
used to berate me on the phone every
time he would get one of my monthly
invoices we made him look like a genius
now I haven't seen him in a long time
but a few years after we launched the
product Cisco had already shipped a
hundred million units of that phone our
phone was everywhere including on the
desk of the President I was pretty
jazzed when I saw that and he stopped
needling me about those monthly invoices
and for me I left this project with much
deeper respect for the hard work of user
centered design but even more
importantly I left this project which
was my last one at IDEO with a
confidence that I could design anything
so take a drink of water here I went on
to join my first startup where I
developed some cool haptic technologies
these are touch technologies that all of
you with a smartphone or a SmartWatch
use every time you scroll up and down or
push a button to select that little
tactile feedback you feel that's
something that I worked on a long time
ago and we license those technologies
actually to many companies which
actually unlocked a goal that I had had
when I had left I do as a consultant
which was how can I make money while I
sleep so I was feeling pretty jazzed
about that we took the company public in
fact immersion is still a public company
today but I was actually itching to
start my own company and so I decided to
head back to Stanford to come to the GSB
so I could actually get smart on that
third circle that business needs circle
this was actually from my business
school application back in 2001 of this
what is now sort of a ubiquitous Venn
diagram you guys see all over campus
I spent my two years at the GSB
experimenting with lots and lots of
ideas and in the summer of 2004 I got a
meeting with mark and Grayson as a
prospective angel investor for this
project that I was working on at the
time this mobile messaging idea now
instead of me getting marks hundred
thousand dollar check I learned in this
first meeting that Mark and Gina
Bianchini his co-founder who was
actually a classmate and friend of my
wife's had actually just found it a new
company under the Stealth name of 24h
Elle 24-hour laundry was what we joked
it meant now mark and Geena wouldn't
share much in the way of details of what
they were working on but this idea had
sprung from mark's passion for platforms
he's a platform guy but also a deep
conviction that the next generation of
consumer internet apps would be social
this was 2004 that they'd be powered by
user-generated content and that they
should be made from common parts that
wouldn't require you to know how to code
so I was pretty fired up about my mobile
messaging concept it actually had built
a few prototypes and mock-ups they gave
me the confidence this was a decent idea
but here's this chance to go join Marc
Andreessen the guy who started the first
browser and go and work on this really
big idea together so Marc and Geena
extend me an offer to join them as a
product manager I wasn't a founder was
actually a product manager and I'm like
come on guys I have all this great
product design experience but I'm not
just a designer I just graduated from
the Stanford GSB I was an RJ Miller
scholar for God's sakes and you're
giving me a product manager role I could
have gone back to immersion as a VP of
Engineering this was a public company at
the time but I was really taken by
Marc's ambition so I accept the job and
a pretty modest equity package though it
feels like I'm starting all over again
take a
not the garbage fortunately within six
weeks or so they promote me to VP and I
show up at my first meeting with mark
and Gina now these were always over
breakfast at the Palo Alto Creamery
where mark was a favorite customer is
there almost every day not anymore
in case you're looking for him and Mark
hands me this tear sheet with no less
than a hundred features that are gonna
be in the v1 product so this thing's
going to have a local guide and groups
and photo sharing and discussion forums
and tagging and ratings and reviews and
like 90 other things so I'm like wow
this feels like a lot but let me go do
some work and I go off and I prototype a
bunch of mock-up apps sort of
demonstration apps including a version
of Stanford's beloved I found an online
version of the Stanford guide to the
good life I have no idea if this exists
anymore but it's one of my favorite
things was filled with coupons and then
I build this clone of yahoogroups
and then I build this cool discussion
forum for a Ford Mustang fanatics and I
come back to our next breakfast meeting
and I share these mock-ups and Mark and
Gina are like whoa that's really cool
but can you add and then Mark hands me a
new tear sheet with like another 50
features we would have to integrate and
this time it's got to have classifieds
and restaurant reviews and an
integration with Google Maps so I go off
and I build another set of prototype
mock-ups including Yelp and Craigslist
clones for all these geographies cities
that didn't that didn't weren't large
enough to actually have these services
on their own so places like Juneau
Alaska literally built a clone of
Craigslist for Juneau and I come back
another Creamery breakfast another 50
features now it's gonna have bedding and
dating and a rumor board oh and it's an
election year so it was also going to
have one of these election markets sort
of like the
Iowa electronics markets that help the
prediction markets and it also had to be
easy enough for non-technical users to
use it but also powerful and flexible
enough that hardcore programmers could
actually really get use out of it
and so I go off and I build more
prototype apps and I begin working on
the app building interface which we
affectionately called the playground and
as this repeat loop breakfast meeting
dynamic continues I begin to become very
uncomfortable with this everything to
everyone
platform strategy and in the midst of
all this Tim O'Reilly launches the first
web 2.0 conference myspace is on fire
Friendster is falling over Facebook is
as still a closed to just universities
and colleges but it's clear that it's
growing like an angry weed and YouTube
blows up on the back of Andy samberg's
lazy Sunday have any of you seen this
some of you
mark of course sees all this stuff
happening as well so you can probably
imagine what happened at the next
Creamery breakfast now our service was
going to have this is actually yet guys
there's gonna have every feature from
every web 2.0 star startup I kind of
joked at the time we were gonna build a
mobile social network video podcasting
with a tag navigatable wiki like put it
all together
whereas Chevy Chase once said it's a
dessert topping and a floor wax and this
is when I decide to tag out so unlike
that's Groundhog Day for those of you
who don't know it so unlike in the case
of the Cisco phone
I was simply unable to manage that
Cambrian explosion
of ideas and features what I ultimately
realized was that platforms in viral
expansion loops as they were called at
the time are a great place to end up but
you're never going to get there if you
don't focus on a single unforgettable
minimally awesome product how many of
you have heard of Ning five six seven of
you but you've all heard of YouTube and
Tumblr and Facebook Ning the one ring
meant to rule them all
was sold to glam for parts now I'm still
proud of the amazing team that we built
and some of those distributed
architecture concepts that we pioneered
still live on actually the data centers
of companies like Facebook and LinkedIn
and others but this story should serve
as a very important reminder that
infinite ambition is actually not a goal
I was actually chastened by this
experience which in so many ways was
like a photo negative of everything I
had learned about bringing great
products into the world trying to be
everything to everyone
ends in being nothing to anyone and it's
only ruthless focus and delivering real
value to real customers to real people
is the only way to win so about six
months later I joined foundation Capital
as an entrepreneur and residence I was
actually working on a few interesting
concepts and about six weeks in one of
the partners pulls me aside and he says
hey you keep bringing these cool
entrepreneurs in why don't you think
about investing and I was like I don't
want to think about investing I'm
working on this great great idea but I
kept introducing people into the firm
and cool startups and a few more months
went by and I realized I'm
having as much fun as I've ever had so I
thought I'd give it a go and I
transitioned to a principal in the fall
of 2007 so here I was a product designer
turned entrepreneur turned investor
excited to take on this very interesting
new challenge but also feeling like I'm
starting all over again
so I spend the next several months going
deep in a few interesting areas in fact
in many ways I actually thought about
early stage investing the same way I had
thought about product design challenges
observe understand synthesize hypotheses
test and iterate on those ideas with the
smartest people that you know in those
areas this was how you built deep points
of view and a zani IR I had spent some
time in this very obscure area known as
solar finance now solar panels had been
around for decades but they were simply
too expensive for anyone but the dark
green rich consumer it was actually
simply dis economic to go solar but in
2005 George W Bush signed into law the
solar investment tax credit which
enabled businesses to capture a 30
percent tax credit on the cost of the
solar systems that they had installed
and with this credit solar could
actually be cheaper than incumbent
electricity now a company called
SunEdison blew open this market
opportunity was called solar as a
service but focused on the commercial
market so for companies like Marriott
hotels Walmart and lots of others and
when I saw Sun Edison's business model I
was immediately taken it was as simple
and beautiful as some of my favorite
products and it didn't take me long to
ask why isn't this same solar as a
service business model also available to
homeowners to residential markets so I
decided to reach out to David Busby who
was the founder of Sun Edison and he
told me why the transaction costs were
simply
- hi and the idea of managing hundreds
of thousands or maybe even if you were
successful millions of small solar
systems on rooftops as compared to
building dozens or hundreds of very
large-scale systems out in fields was
just too much brain damage and they had
no interest in taking us on which
actually made me even more interested in
learning more so I went and figured out
the four things that you had to get
right in order to build this company you
had to have the capital structure to be
able to buy millions of systems the
operating shops to actually manage them
you had to be able to navigate the
gnarly regulatory landscape and then you
had to be able to offer a single simple
offering to end consumers and then
through one of my Stanford Business
School classmates I got a warm
introduction to Linder rich and Edie
Fenster they were two Stanford GSB
students a few years behind me and they
had just started a residential solar as
a service company so I invited Lynn and
Ed down to present on a Friday afternoon
they walk me through their pitch and it
was as if I had been hit over the head
with a hammer between the two of them
they had figured out all the things you
had to get right in order to blow this
market opportunity open lynn was a
brilliant force of nature and a
strategist the financial savant when you
literally could not genetically engineer
a better founding duo to take on this
opportunity so I brought Ed Lynn back in
the following business day literally the
next partner meeting on Monday to
present to our full partners my partners
were very impressed actually in spite of
this was the this is literally the deck
this is the cover sheet of the deck they
were the fastest growing and fifth
largest residential solar company in
California so they needed some work to
do on marketing Lynn really hates it
when I show this slide but my partners
were impressed but they had a few big
questions this was a business model
innovation not a technological one
and it wasn't clear at all to them my
partners that this couldn't be copied in
a minute that solar investment tax
credit I talked about earlier it was
actually set to expire later that year
and while there was some congressional
momentum that it was going to get
extended this wasn't a given at all
and finally there was a question about
me if this project was so great could I
actually win it would they take me on
their board I mean I was seven months
into my stint as an investor I was just
a principal not a partner my only prior
investment was a $10,000 check behind
Tristan Harris is a good guy and he's
spoken here and Here I am suggesting
that we write a single-handed eight
million dollar investment behind two
first-time entrepreneurs working on a
financial arbitrage opportunity in
renewable energy an area we didn't
really know a lot about so what am I
gonna do I just dig in with all I've got
and for most startups it's actually
pretty easy to tear down their unit
economics and understand their operating
plans and financial models but this
business was like nothing else that we
had seen before it had a crazy
complicated capital structure with
equity and tax equity and debt and
construction loans so I went and I build
built my own detailed financial model to
prove to myself and to my partners that
this was not going to be easy to copy if
we figured it out but more importantly
that if they were successful this model
would actually scale not just with the
investment tax credit but much much
further along
and then there was that risk that
regulatory risk around the solar
investment tax credit this could
literally go away with the stroke of a
pen we've seen this by the way the last
couple of years now these aren't the
things that a typical Silicon Valley
software startup has to worry about but
in this case I had to reach out to
regulators and lobbyists people in
Washington DC and Sacramento and cities
that I had never been to before and
these were not people who are in the
rolodexes of a typical venture
capitalist at the time but I needed them
to help understand whether the solar
investment tax credit was actually gonna
get extended now even haven't done all
of this work it wasn't going to be easy
to win this project I couldn't do it on
my own at the end of the day I've
learned something about venture capital
and that it is a team sport to win these
investments so I rallied my partners
that foundation capital and we wrapped
our arms around Lynn and Ed we showed
them that we really understood their
business and what it would take to win
and remember David Busby the founder of
Sun Edison and my sounding board with Ed
and Lynn's permission I was able to loop
him in to my due diligence and when he
began to tear it down and see what I saw
he asked if he could join us alongside
in the investment round so within two
weeks of that fateful Friday meeting we
had signed a term sheet to buy 30% of
the company now I've just made my first
investment you kind of sit back and wait
for the money to roll in right that's
what this job looks like I know you all
think that but there was this other
remaining thing that we had to figure
out and that was we had to raise another
50 million dollars of
tax equity so this was the capital that
we would use to actually buy the systems
not the eight million dollars to fund
the operating company and the original
plan was to do this by the end of June
2008 and was about a month after we had
invested in the company the end of June
comes and goes and July it's still not
done
August not done then comes September
2008 Lehman went bust at midnight on
September 15th and then seemingly every
day for the rest of the month another
legendary financial institution blows up
the bottom literally fell out of the
financial markets so here I am three
months into my first investment as a VC
and the world is literally teetering on
collapse but the team powered through
and they signed a term sheet on
September 26 was a Friday with US bank
for 40 million dollars of tax equity
this little ray of hope we might make it
through and then the following business
day the House of Representatives votes
down a 700 billion dollar financial
bailout plan and the dow dropped 778
points in a single day largest slide
ever we had a term sheet that's great
but it's just a piece of paper and when
the world ends all bets are off so we
pushed everyone the team US bank and all
the lawyers who I don't think have
forgiven us still as hard as we could to
close the deal which we did barely in
the nick of time within a few weeks the
capital markets had completely frozen
over
and as Eadie described it at the time we
had just flown the last helicopter out
of Saigon
now SunRun experienced many more
white-knuckle moments over the next
handful of years they all do in 2012 the
US Treasury so the government literally
sued the company along with all of our
competitors everyone in the market and
then there was this time when one of the
investors who the company had turned
down for one of the rounds of investment
was so upset that the company had passed
on their investment that they went and
funded the founder the original owner
registrant of sex calm to create a
capping copycat of our business now this
didn't work out so well as you might
imagine but the team and I had a long
enough focal length the kind of whether
these near-term ups and downs and today
SunRun has more than 180,000 customers
in just 15 of the 50 states and there
are 30 million more homes to go so we
took the company public in August of
2015 at a market cap just north of 1.3
billion dollars Lin in the center there
co-founder and CEO and brand new mom
she's our 3-month old with her got to
ring the bell
and I got that unicorn I've made another
20 or so investments over the last 10
years at foundation capital and each one
of them serves as kind of another canvas
for another startup story but let me
just wrap it up with the three lessons
that I have learned over and over again
in my career learn how to sell for Steve
snow blowing this meant knocking on the
door and asking for the order an I do
this was about advocating for end users
and the design process itself in that
foundation this has meant cultivating
authentic relationships with
entrepreneurs and figure
airing out how to help them achieve
their goals whatever this means for you
with the business that you want to go
build just swallow your fears and do it
to design matters not just the
aesthetics or the pixels on the
snow-blowing flyer but design as the
what what problem are you going to solve
what opportunity are you going to go
after what positive impact do you want
to have in the world as I learned to do
at IDEO and fail to do at Ning focus on
meeting real needs and wants
find simplicity on the other side of
complexity now let me do a shameless
plug here if you want to learn more
about this check out as Tina mentioned
the way to design which is a book that I
launched last year and an audio book if
you're more into audio books I released
just a couple of weeks ago you can find
that over on the way to design calm but
back to the third lesson take out the
garbage roll up your sleeves and rush to
pound down those unglamorous tasks I'm
struck by how many young Stanford alums
I meet and have worked with and only
their third month on the job are already
asking hey when do I get to be the CEO
I really admire the ambition but
remember you're in the building mode of
your careers so be willing to sublimate
your ego but don't subordinate your
values and one more thing you all are so
fortunate to be here at Stanford it's
literally ground zero for
entrepreneurial thought leaders you all
have a lot going for you
but as you all also know success is not
guaranteed so when you do find it
savor it have fun and enjoy the ride
and that's all I got
cool and of course everyone else can ask
questions too so here you are designer
at a VC firm haven't you changed the way
your partners think about design how has
your presence there influenced the
culture and that the way they they look
at opportunities that come their way
yeah I think it's a great question and
it's it's one where what I've observed
as as venture capital has gotten smarter
on design and the role of design the
reflexive instinct is actually to bring
in what is often called as a designer
residence and I think the firms are
doing this mostly as a service to their
portfolio companies you know so that you
can help them out with some of their
kind of critical go to market and
product challenges which is a great
service to have in some cases although
most companies need their own designers
interaction designers or human factors
people I think what's different about
our approach at foundation is that we're
not doing design as a service bolt-on we
think about design kind of in a more
functional and sort of core way so not
as the aesthetics if you will but more
so what question are you asking and so
for example as I began that as I worked
on the book one of the things I was very
fortunate to do is to talk to 50 amazing
designer founders entrepreneurs design
historians and scholars and through the
course of those interviews 200 pages of
notes I saw some patterns and in those
patterns I think what emerged what was
clear was you needed to kind of reframe
design from that little D from that sort
of tweaking and tuning instinct from the
drapes and the drop shadows if you will
to sort of this question of design as
the reframing of what problem are you
trying to solve and so whereas when I
first started to talk about design my
participate bring in Steve he's the guy
with the cool shoes no it's not about
that design is about what questions
you're asking and so I think they all
now have been trained but I also think
it's really important that when you do
engage with the venture firm if you do
care about design design as a bolt-on
very rarely works it's for the same
reason why many of those consultancies
design cults consultancies that get you
know scooped up by
IBM or McKinsey or or or General
Electric often times that that stuff
actually doesn't work so not a bolt-on
think about its core yeah we didn't
extra you still inside one another vcp
miss you know I eat not to get it can
yeah sorry the question was and and
correct me if I don't get it completely
are there companies where we invest and
then they don't hit their milestones and
and then we don't want to invest any
longer but we want someone else to
invest that doesn't usually work I mean
I think I think what's challenging about
those kinds of situations and they
happened in every venture firm is
companies you know milestones slide to
the right just like they did at Sun Run
but what that ends up doing is it calls
into question you know are you too early
for example or maybe the product really
doesn't deserve to exist maybe this
thing is kind of a neat idea was Bank
thing but there's no market for it and
so what we typically do is if we've
invested a material amount of capital
and and something's not working we
actually kind of build a sub team around
that company and we figure out whether
we still believe in other words whether
whether if this company were able to
kind of continue forward is there still
an interesting market for it and if we
believe that that's true then we will
actually reinvest in that company
sometimes it requires sort of
restructuring the company and that
restructuring can attract other
investors in so if they think oh this is
actually a really good team maybe
they're two years too early but would be
willing to actually join you on that so
it happens occasionally but keep in mind
every startup so we were early investors
in Netflix Netflix as a public company
almost ran out of money five times it
went public at a 350 million dollar
market cap by the way blockbuster was a
three billion dollar company at the time
and you've used blockbuster anymore yeah
one you do so so they all hit they all
hit their their snags even the most
successful ones yeah game faces and
you know that anyway I had this us
people there's we know our IP they get
so what is your feeling these days and
in the future what's your pistol one
saying about use any custom I've learned
that I can't predict these things
anything and and you know I think you
just gotta roll with the punches and
figure out how to manage those but but
those you know those Doc's are helpful
from time to time but most folks are
actually doing all that stuff without
having to circulate a presentation so
yeah sorry the question sorry I didn't
repeat the last question either I
restarted I started over three times in
my career what was that like sounds kind
of crazy and scary I did absolutely and
it was really scary
and I also loved it I you know still run
a business silly kind of product
business on the side it keeps keeps my
creative juices flowing I'm sort of a
person who loves to learn new things and
so I was fired up by those challenges
but I was also aware of the fact that
that I wasn't always necessarily the
right person as I was in those early
kind of building mode hence to sort of
learn when you need to gotta go back to
taking out the garbage yeah yeah when
someone tells you I want s but you think
actually I think what you need is why
how do you determine when you're
actually correct
and when you
and their needs better than they do
versus trusting that they actually
understand their goods how do you
differentiate the answer absolutely
depends because if I'm talking to
someone who's spent thousands of hours
focused on some market opportunity and
they have evidence to prove that you
know their point of view is the right
one then I then I and I respect that
but in general I think I'm I'm very
practical about these things and I would
love to sort of most cases again turn
these things into design challenges
that's my instinct that's what like if
you if you said sort of what is the
thing you always go back to across all
three times have changed you know
changing careers I was imprinted like a
baby duck here at Stanford on these
design you know as sort of design
challenges and so I go back to
prototyping hypothesizing sharing those
ideas with the best and smartest people
that I know and I gather as much data as
I can but that's that's all I know how
to do really that's the skill under at
all yeah in the back so when we invest
in a company what are the things that we
look for is that they're a team or a
market yeah that's a question so do we
index on one thing over another you know
when I started in the career or in
venture capital I remember one of my
partners Mike's you you know rely on me
of the five things and it was market
team technology or product the business
model itself and then of course one
thing that has nothing to do with the
company but more to do with us which was
the expected return on a dollar invested
so those are the five things but I have
learned in my experience that the team
is the one thing that can for example
adjust the product or technology or can
find the new market when the first one
doesn't work out so I over index
probably and sometimes perhaps too much
so on on the team and I think that also
is informed by the further along you get
in your career you realize it's how you
spend your time that be
is very very important and I want to
work with people who I can imagine
working with like Lin who I've been
working with now literally for 10 years
so team is a really really important
thing for me wow this was really
fabulous thank you so much for sharing
these insights in your story please do I
mean thank you
[Applause]